the scherzer makes his eighth start with
the dodgers they've won each of the
first seven he's got a one zero five era
in those seven games in dodger blue
and a change up that's what walker
mueller leveraged so well last night to
get scherzer his first strikeout of the
night is
2995th in the big leagues five more and
he's got three thousand
flipped into center field from mookie
betts out there for the first time since
julie finishes off a one two three first
inning for max scherzer with blake snow
on the bound today for the padres well
they need a big one from the left-hander
and he has been the big time pitcher the
last uh hand full of times out makes his
27th start for blake snell turner two
outs bases empty
ooh snow oh
no something just grabbed at him i don't
know it was the groin or what
but that pitch he walks off the mound
after that delivery he's done
wow and that looks like a groin
from what he was kind of grabbing at and
he's gonna walk
right off the field okay so this is
something that he has had either in this
first inning or when he was warming up
or something
and it just goes there bill enters his
36th game you know he'll chew up innings
that's uh that's his role he knows that
he accepts that
trey turner at second base
and justin turner lines out to third
machado able to make the catch
[Applause]
it is marched to 3 000.
nine pitches
nine strikes three
[Music]
inning for will smith
swings at the 2-2 and drives it out to
deep left field back goes fam at the
wall he leaps and makes the catch
right at the wall tommy pham they have
brought that ball back time the leap
makes the catch two down nice play by
tommy pham six up six down for max
scherzer including an immaculate inning
here comes the payoff
got him
he's won away
as he struck out four in a row now
sitting on 2999
career strikeouts
two outs here in the third inning and
that'll bring up max muncie here's the
01. muncie swings hits a little tapper
out in front of the plate nola calls off
chris matt picks it up with the bare
hand throw to first is just in time and
the inning is over five strikeouts in
this one and two thousand nine hundred
ninety nine in his big league career
scherzer's payoff pitch
off the hands
short right center field turner and
zieger and it's sega to make the catch
adam frazier contact hitter line to
right in his first at-bat
and he bounces a one-hopper to max
muncie jogs to the bag frazier's retired
there's two out 11 up 11 down for the
day two gone in the fourth inning here's
manny machado
[Applause]
[Music]
they all say and we do too the straight
turner makes the catch we've got a
pitchers duel working right here turner
is going to lead it off here for the
dodgers
staying away and did he go yes he did
home plate umpire corsigal going to ring
him up
2-2 hard hit grounder off of lumet rolls
to frazier at second base he's got it
and the throw to first is in time
scoreless two out of the bottom of the
fourth seeger flied out his first time
driven to center field grisham to the
wall it's gone
there's the first one of the day on a
sega home run hello cory hello lead and
we are still amazed that teams will
throw a notorious first ball swinger a
strike that loads the bases with three
walks they're gonna take their chances
with scherzer
ground ball softly hit machado got hung
up with the runner a little bit but
still makes the play 2
999 one away from becoming the 19th
member of the 3000 strikeout club
the 19th member of the 3 000 strikeout
club
is max scherzer september 12
2021 will be the birthday of his 3 000
strikeout
flight into right on a bright day bets
has it spotted and while he gets his
3000 k he's also gone 15 up 15 down
boogie bets leading off this fifth the
01 the bets
there's a shot to left that one's well
hit fam goes back to the wall gone a
home run
boy mookie bets on fire down the stretch
last night a home run a sac fly a single
and four rbis
home run number 21 on this sunday
afternoon sure in the dodgers lead two
to nothing leading it off
paints the outside corner for out number
one of the six
so not only does he strike you out not
only does he pitch you deep in the game
he keeps his pitch count in a very
healthy place
a pop fly fog around first base side
smith has room
and makes the catch at the last moment
he found it for the second out of the
six
jake maris nick sent up as the pinch
hitter in the nine spot scherzer's one
two
he's perfect through six
on to the seventh top of the order
coming up
flies the first one into right bets
straining straining drifting
adam frazier who has hit him well in his
career
slide the left
lux is there and he comes back from 3-0
to get frazier got eight k's today he's
gone 20 up and 20 down
a q shot back to schrozer who is perfect
through seven
first and third one gone dodgers looking
for some insurance
[Applause]
and it's three nothing two away for
turner running the bank but looking for
more
[Music]
[Applause]
he delivers to tatis
fly ball to right the sun has played a
factor all day mookie's there he's got
it located in out number one he is five
outs away osmer struck out twice today
first base runner of the game comes with
one gone here in the eighth a double
from hosmer and he falls five out shy of
perfection two gone from myers second
[Applause]
but he's got eight shutout innings
against the padres
once he flies it into left center field
fam will make the catch spell ems your
heads for the plate
another rbi for muncie and an eight
nothing lead back to the top and grisham
oh for three today and one for his last
22.
rule almost made a play behind the back
instead it's seeger to finish it off
what a day at the ballpark an eight
nothing win for the dodgers where
scherzer flirts with perfection
while getting his 3 000th career
strikeout